[Music]
Selena Gomez and the weekend call it
quits after just ten months of dating a
source close to Selena tells ET the
breakup came down to their priority
after the hands to myself singer
underwent a life-saving kidney
transplant with her bestie France dia
this summer I guess I got to the point
where it was it was really kind of life
or death
quote Selena really relied on her
friends as opposed to the weekend
he just wasn't really available to drop
everything he had going on to be with
her full time here with the right group
of people it's all that matters
another big issue that caused the
relationship to crumble Selena's group
of friends never really liked her
boyfriend our source adds quote he's not
part of the church group and at this
point those friends and her faith mean
everything to her my family and friends
I'm just a really happy place
okay give each other company
the split news comes just after Selena
started hanging with her ex Justin
Bieber again in the last week or so
they've been spotted multiple times
together at Hillsong Church even another
source tells ET Selena never stops
caring for Justin adding quote the
kidney transplant Rhys parked their
friendship selena and Justin always have
each other's backs so does this mean
Justin and Selena are rekindling their
romance our source says the duo doesn't
want to jeopardize their friendship
quote don't expect them to jump into
anything too quickly exactly and it can
ruin everything